[Music]
hello i'm facimo silveira assistant
engineer with the google cloud cortex
team
and if you're interested in learning
about the cortex application layer then
this video is for you
the cortex application layer can be used
as a blueprint for you to view
distributed and scalable applications to
securely consume information from the
cortex-data foundation content resulting
in bigquery
our scalable data cloud warehouse
it is composed of the following services
and provides you a blueprint to get
started
quickly an even driven architecture
using pop server
uneven source this is usually your
system of record for demonstration we
are using cloud scheduling
a controller service in this case an
inventory should query inventory levels
a data access layer that will securely
access bigquery
an output service to publish the results
for a query through website
the blueprint provided allow you to
easily add other microservices with
additional functionality and reuse the
secure data access and output patterns
created
for example
you could use a synchronous call to
complement master data when creating it
in a system of record like sap or
publish a message about new stock
requirements for your different
demanding planning systems to subscribe
and consume
you can deploy the cortex application
layer simple content from the
marketplace for quick access navigate to
the cortex short link on the screen
now let's see this in action
first we navigate to the marketplace
page however before deploying you need
to complete the setup's instructions
outlined on the deployment instructions
guide
this guide has a comprehensive steps to
configure your environment
at the end of this guide you have all
the information you need in order to
deploy the application content in your
project
i have already completed the steps and
this is the output of the last step in
the compilation we are ready to deploy
let's go ahead and click on configure
and start populating our views with the
correct parameters
simply copy the fields in the correct
place
for the reporting dataset this should be
the name of the dataset where you deploy
the cortex data foundation modules
which in this example is the same
project with the name unicorn reporting
complete the remaining fields
when ready click deploy
at this stage the application is
creating the components we saw in the
diagram
in addition as part of the deployments
the sample code for this application is
added to the cloud source repository for
you to browse and modify
check the readme for detailed breakdown
of components and best practices
you now have a blueprint on how to
consume cortex data foundation insights
from your downstream business
applications deployed on your project
learn more by clicking on the link in
the description below
enjoy
you